Democrats versus Republicans Republicans
versus Democrats Democrats versus
Democrats Republicans versus Republicans
politics man America the Ides of March
and as I don't see every trailer that
comes out I didn't know much about this
movie
I just thought Ryan Gosling in a George
Clooney movie in fall which is around
Oscar season that dude is going for the
Oscar this year for sure Ryan Gosling
was like you bastards passed me up for
an Oscar in 2010 I will be back in 2011
to get that [ __ ] right so this movie
stars Ryan Gosling who's this really
idealistic campaign manager for George
Clooney who's a senator running for the
primaries to be the next president who's
also an idealistic politician however
things might not be what they seem
including town now this baby's kind of a
mixed bag for me yes I did like it and
it's well done however it is a bit slow
but it's really well acted dude like
George Clooney's perfect for the role
he's in you listen to him give his
speeches you're like all right I'm with
you George Clooney for president
apparently and Ryan Gosling we know by
now the dudes a good actor when he plays
a role he's gonna hit it out of the park
and he's really good in this role he's
charismatic he's charming he's a good
talker he's the man the supporting cast
was really good too you got Philip
Seymour Hoffman Paul Giamatti even
Marissa Tomei who she was good but she
wasn't in it much at this point she kind
of looks like Carrie Fisher does now
they're kind of like the Constructicons
zan transformers yeah they're really
badass by themselves but when you stack
a bunch of awesome supporting actors
together to like this unstoppable force
called the Devastator and that's the
cartoon not the shitty stupid second
movie in which he was a bulldog who
climbed up a pyramid that was [ __ ]
and Evan Rachel Wood zan Evan Rachel
Wood is a really good actress I didn't
really know that much about her I mean
in True Blood she was just like the hot
Queen chick oh my gosh she's way hot and
I found out she was banging Marilyn
Manson and I always heard in high school
that it looks like Marilyn Manson with
no makeup and if that means I get Evan
Rachel Wood I'm fine with that but in
this movie she's a good actress I was
like all right props to you you're hot
and a good actress I saying hot
actresses can't be good actresses I'm
just saying it surprised me dude the big
question is who's the better actor in
this movie Philip Seymour Hoffman or
Paul Giamatti I don't know because
Philip Seymour Hoffman had a monologue
in this movie and I was like Philip
Seymour Hoffman is the best supporting
actor in this movie then Paul Giamatti
had a monologue and I was like Paul
Giamatti is the best supporting actor in
this movie so I just don't know who was
better I think Paul Giamatti by a hair
and when I walked out of this movie I
was like I like the
except I like a lot of things about it
it was a little slow but you know it was
good but then I really started thinking
about it it's one of those movies like
you like and more as you think about it
I don't think two hours is enough time
to show all the points you know show all
the dirty politics and the campaign
trail and show how it all affects
everything this would have been a
perfect story to show unlike TV not like
TV TV not like basic cable but HBO you
know where they show the boardwalk and
the Empire it's kind of like that you
know you watch Boardwalk Empire and
you're like it's slow but it's
interesting and I like it if for nothing
else it should be shown in high schools
teachers should show this to their
students and be like all right we're not
gonna [ __ ] you anymore politics suck
and this is why playing politics without
playing dirty politics is like bringing
a knife to a gunfight it just is it
sucks I wish it wasn't but it is this
movie addresses that in a pretty good
way if you're into like realistic dirty
politics this is your movie the movie
gets a lot cooler when you stop seeing
it as like oh yeah it's a fictional
piece of work and see it more like yeah
this [ __ ] happens all the time what you
see it as a reality you're like oh yeah
it's awesome in the end I will say it's
an interesting time no alcohol required
calling it a good time to alcohol
required I don't think fits it just
doesn't the context is not there I'm not
gonna ask your political stance but your
favorite political movie what is it
comment below let me know
and yes Bulworth counts and as always if
you liked what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more punching the camera is not PC
[Music]